there is a video going around of Dr
fauci and it's very high quality footage
and the audio is really great and it's
weird it seems like a movie because it
is a movie it's it's being made by PBS
and it's following Dr fauci and the DC
mayor a Muriel Bowser going around DC
neighborhoods in 2021 to try to convince
people to take the fauci ouchy there's a
clip going around right now that
I think the producers believed showed Dr
fauci to be reasonable
to be scientific to be level-headed and
show these residents of DC to be
complete just knuckle dragging backward
idiots
that however is not with the clips
actually show people in America are not
settled with the information that's been
given to us right now so I'm not going
to be lining up taking a shot on a
vaccination for something that wasn't
clear in the first place and then you
all create a shot and miraculous
yes
well it used to take years okay you know
how you know how many years were
invested in this in this approach about
20 years of science to get us to be able
to do not enough
I love that guy's answer because Dr
fauci is
speaking in a way that's very vague and
he's kind of blurring the truth
obviously the covid vaccine had not been
developed for 20 years because kovid had
just occurred a year prior
after it escaped from the Wuhan wet
Market allegedly or more likely was
engineered in a Chinese bio lab it
didn't exist 20 years ago it didn't
exist 20 months prior to to Dr fauci's
uh commentary here where thereabouts so
he's saying well the technology using
the MRNA to do the who's he what's this
with the jigab that's been around
forever it's 20 years and the guy is not
having it the DC resident he says yeah
that's not long enough either bro like
whatever BS you're spewing right now we
just all know this is a new experimental
drug and I don't want to take it keep
going it's definitely not enough for
nobody to be taking no vaccination that
you all came up with the only reason I'm
talking to you right now as close as we
are is that I've been vaccinated right
but if it allowed thousands of people
like you don't get vaccinated you're
going to let this virus continue to
percolate in this country and in this
world something like the common flu then
right and that's like that's much more
serious than the flu but oh yeah totally
way more yeah you know how many people
died of the flu the last year I mean not
this year virtually none but the
previous year about 20 to 30 000 you
know how many people have died from
covid-19 in the United States 600 000
Americans well well that well the number
that you all given that died that's
that's once again that's you all's
number you put a pause there this is
brilliant this guy as Dr fauci is
throwing out these numbers oh yeah this
this vaccine it's 20 years in
development obviously it's not road
because the virus didn't exist until
very recently oh listen seven bazillion
people died from covid last year well no
what have we learned since then we've
learned
that many of those numbers uh many of
the people who supposedly died from
covid actually just died with covid so
they had Advanced stage cancer and then
they happened to have this virus when
they died the virus didn't kill them the
virus can't be said to be the cause of
their death they just had it when they
died the extreme version of this would
be someone gets shot in the head but
they tested positive for covet okay it's
a covet death well I don't think so
that's pretty far down the list of
things that killed that person and and
this guy this regular old Joe from
Washington DC is looking Dr fauci the
representative of science right in the
face and he says you're putting numbers
out right now that I simply don't
believe yeah definitely because when you
start talking about paying people to get
vaccinated when you start talking about
incentivizing things to get people
vaccinated there's something else going
on with that put a pause there why did
Bill de Blasio the mayor of New York
have to say if you get vaccinated we'll
give you a cheeseburger and yummy French
do it here we're gonna bribe you to take
the vaccine if it's such a great vaccine
if the virus is so dangerous if there is
no risk from the vaccine and it's so
effective why wouldn't people be begging
clamoring to get that vaccine why did
the establishment have to bribe people
there's something weird going on here as
this DC resident says
you're right
like me and almost everybody here didn't
get us there you know what their
incentive was protecting their health
and protecting the cities
your campaign is about fear it's about
inciting fearing people you all attack
people with fear that's what this
pandemic is it's a fear is feared it's
pandemic what is that guy's name how can
I get all my DC resident friends to
elect him to city council because that
guy that guy gets it
the the funniest part of this clip to me
is it was filmed and produced to make
him seem like the unreasonable one and
to make Bowser and fauci seem like the
reasonable ones and yet given the facts
that we know now on vaccine efficacy
when it comes to preventing infection
and transmission of the virus what did
Muriel Bowser say right there she said
I'm standing this close to you because
I'm vaccinated so I'm not at any risk
here I'm not going to spread that virus
that's not true
we know that the virus that the vaccine
didn't do very much at all to stop
infection or prevention
or or transmission rather of the virus
what did the vaccine do eventually they
said well okay it doesn't do any of the
things that we initially said it would
do but it'll totally reduce the severity
of the illness it'll greatly reduce risk
of death and hospitalization I know
we've been wrong about all our other
predictions but trust us on that one
because it's pretty much unfalsifiable
yeah yeah
that guy was right that was her and
fauci were wrong
on the death numbers
how many
localities revised down their death
number
after covid because there were errors in
the data and these people who died with
kovid were tabulated as having died from
covid
the the the regular Joe on the street
got it the genius scientists did not get
it that tells you so much of what you
need to know about this current regime
which has lost pretty much all of its
culpability because it lies to us all
the time and about politics generally
regular people have a pretty good gut
instinct they might not have the most
advanced scientific studies out of Johns
Hopkins but those studies
those scientific studies are generally
speaking a lot less reliable than the
gut instincts of normal people who are
well-formed and well adjusted to the
world this is out of UCI
the University of California Irvine
the Nader zones on distant planets could
Harbor life
you see Irvine astronomers say
these in between regions could be prime
sites for liquid water
in a new study University of California
Irvine astronomers describe how
extraterrestrial life has the potential
to exist on distant exoplanets inside a
special area called The Terminator Zone
which is a ring on planets that always
have one side facing its star on one
side that's always in the dark
and the thing is
um
no they couldn't
the thing is I'm not even going to read
the rest of the article I'm certainly
not going to read the study
uh no the Terminator zones could not
Harbor life because extraterrestrial
aliens aren't real they're not real and
the limbs just they love it they were so
fascinated by it it's just it made me
think
about how many completely ridiculous
things the libs believe in and yet they
call us the gullible ones they call us
the Fantastical ones
the libs believe in catastrophic global
warming is going to kill us all in five
minutes the libs believe that boys can
secretly be girls and girls can secretly
be boys and the libs believe
in E.T it's not real there is
I know this is controversial on the
right I know my colleague Matt Walsh
here is very pro-eat there is
zero evidence
that extraterrestrial life exists
anywhere
zero the the best evidence they can
musterers well the universe is really
big okay yeah
a really really big and really really
cold and really really empty and devoid
of Life the the reason the libs have to
believe that there's extraterrestrial
life is because they have to believe
that humans are not special they have to
believe that man is not made in the
image and likeness of God they have to
believe that there's no real Rhyme or
Reason to the universe that there's no
intention that there's no forwarding
Providence they have to believe that
it's all just random chance
and if it's all just kind of random and
it all just kind of crops up life is
just wherever it pops up because of
certain material conditions
then they they can lead themselves to
believe that extraterrestrial life
exists
but they have they they believe in it to
justify their own stupid religious views
and their own false anthropological
views and their own mistakes about
everything in the real world it is not
real keep looking guys good I hope you
see Irvine I hope all of these liberal
universities I hope they spend all their
time looking for et and all these other
planets so they spend less time focused
on social policy here in the United
States to screw up our society based on
their similarly false premises good keep
looking for et but we conservatives can
know
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member
and use code Knowles kwles check out for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]